emotional maturity is a state few of us
ever reach or at least not for very long
but it may help us to try to lay out
what some of the ingredients are so that
we can have an idea of what we might aim
for if we were to grow into emotionally
mature people this is some of what we
would have learned how to be we would
strive to understand the specific ways
in which our childhoods had made us
crazy we would accept that most of what
we are is shaped by relatively small
events that unfold before we are 10
years old we would probably go and find
a good
therapist there we would start to notice
the patterns perhaps we wouldn't need to
keep trying to impress older figures of
Authority or fall in love with distant
people who are involved with someone
else we would acquire a low resolution
map of our
Neurosis there would be a little more
delay between feeling something and
having to act on it we might even at
times simply observe a feeling and do
nothing we could bear to listen we would
no longer cut across and say oh that
reminds me of something just as another
person started to share their story we
would soothe our own wounded egos into
silence look warmly into their eyes and
say tell me more this sounds so
interesting fewer people would strike us
as being either very good or very bad we
would sense the struggle in everyone to
keep afloat we would judge that we were
all a mixture of the good-hearted and
the egoistic we would have less of an
Impulse to Stone
wrongdoers we would take measures to
stay pessimistic about how things turn
out we would remind ourselves on an
hourly basis that all relationships are
Riven with pain all business ventures
are maddening and all families are
demented we wouldn't feel so persecuted
this is just how things universally are
it's just that other people carefully
admit to speak about it we would get
less hopeful and therefore less bitter
and less Furious of course things are
often slightly disastrous of course we
have made some terrible mistakes of
course we have been betrayed and treated
badly but it would all start to feel
eminently and supremely
normal we would stop lamenting our wrong
turns yes we probably did marry the
wrong person we probably did choose the
wrong career probably we are living in
the wrong country and definitely the
wrong house we did invest in useless
things we befriended unworthy sorts we
made awful errors bringing up our
children we neglected our health we'd be
starting to get it right if we lived to
be about a thousand years old or could
do half a dozen practice
runs we'd realize that there is no
manual on how to live everyone is just
making it up as they go along long no
one is normal and no one understands
more than a bit of anything we would
Marvel at the passage of the years
growing old what a strange thing to
happen to a little boy or girl we would
have been through a sufficient number of
Summers and Winters to know that things
do pass eventually what looks at one
time like a mountain will over the years
be worn down to a pebble some of our
greatest losses won't even register
anymore with time what we're weeping
about today will make no sense a while
from now they say you'll get over it and
you will we would laugh more richly
because we had capitulated to Life's
darkest
truths this is some of what we might
think and feel if we ever became those
Paragons of true intelligence
emotionally mature people